once you came to Los Angeles you
probably saw that a lot of people that
had chosen the artists path it was a
little trickier to actually you know
support a family how did you decide to
incorporate you know your knowledge of
contract law and all these other things
with the creative what's interesting
because the biggest thing with with law
school is law school doesn't really it's
not all about teaching you the law the
biggest thing for me with law school was
that it it teaches you how to think and
it just rearranges your brain in such a
way that you can now approach any
problem and really be able to
deconstruct it in a different way to
find an eventual solution and so when I
got out here it was you know I didn't go
to film school and so now I needed to
figure out how to break in just like the
you know hundred thousand other people
that do that every month and but I
looked at the problem of breaking in and
in a different way I think I was
thinking about it differently because
the line of screenwriters that are very
talented the line of directors that are
very talented those lines are very long
and it was very competitive they're all
trying to go through a couple different
doors and for me I wanted to try to
figure out how to differentiate myself
in the marketplace find a different door
in into the industry and and I come from
a really interesting varied background
where you know I was I was a heavy
creative writer in high school I played
a lot of tabletop role-playing games
like Dungeons & Dragons but not dungeons
dragons things like that they when I was
in college I wrote for the stage a lot I
invented board games to sell off the
licensers and manufacturers just through
this bizarre hobby then once I got into
law school obviously I had my my legal
training but also wrote and produced for
the screen while I was in law school so
I so understand and sort of these
bizarre skill sets that I have I wanted
to figure out how to leverage all those
things to help differentiate myself in
the marketplace to try to find a
different way yeah I quickly hooked up
with a couple people once I was out here
one guy that a comic book and a
technology background another guy that
had a music background he had 20 years
in the music industry
and another guy that had the branding
and marketing background
so we're all sitting around the table
working on a pilot project and we
thought okay how do i how do we use all
these other things that we have as a way
to help leverage our project in a
different way how do we create this this
pilot but at the same time incorporate a
boardgame component incorporate some
technology or a comic component how do
we approach it in a brand building way
rather than entertainment way and it was
really for this fascinating subject for
me and it was a fascinating problem to
try to solve once we started trying to
do that then that kind of got me to into
the area of transmedia but I don't think
I would have done could have done that
if I hadn't analyzed the problem
differently from a legal perspective
because if there's there's you know the
industry is is wildly complicated but at
the same time it's very similar to the
way it's been run for the last 50
hundred years and so for me just sitting
back coming in and completely fresh eyes
I looked at the way the industry was
built and the way it was constructed and
a lot of it didn't make sense then a lot
of the the path that most people were
taken seemed to be not a logical path
because it was a wreck running headlong
into the problems rather than trying a
different path to solve the problem
Einstein always said that you can't you
can't solve a problem with the same
thinking that caused it and so so I
looked at the problem looked at it
differently and thought we could take a
different path and so so that that got
me to where I am now which is using all
the tools that are disposal all the
mediums and platforms that all our
disposal in order to try to attack the
the industry in a completely different
way so where most people attack sort of
the industry from a right-brain creative
yeah you were coming from this left
brain sort of analytical critical
thinking sure interesting so that's
that's where you said they sort of
taught you a different way around it
yeah whereas the long line was thinking
from this right brain well if I create
this amazing story it doesn't matter
I'll be let in yeah exactly and that's
it you know and it it's interesting
because I'm not even once
I don't even wanna see that's that's the
wrong way because it's it's the more
competitive way and so for me you know
you could have it you can have a
lemonade stand in a neighborhood and
it's gonna be great but if there's a
hundred other lemonade stands that pop
up in your same neighborhood you have to
start looking at how you approach your
business differently it's not just make
how to make better lemonade like because
it cuz a certain point it's really
difficult to make better lemonade right
I mean and all these other people making
lemonade are gonna try to be trying to
make better lemonade and then it just
becomes very very difficult to try to
stand out in the lemonade business when
there's so many people trying to make
lemonade and so it's not just the
quality that has to improve which that
that's sort of a given we you also have
to just approach the the business of it
from a different way in order to
separate yourself in the marketplace
most people we most people say if I
can't make better lemonade then I'm just
going to do something else which I don't
think is a I don't think is the answer
because if if God puts you on earth to
make lemonade you make lemonade if
you're supposed to be a screenwriter
you'd be a screenwriter but you have to
approach it differently in order to be
competitive
you